DYLAN THOMAS: Welcome to this
episode of "Behind The Map."
This is an occasional
series, where
we talk with Googlers who
work on the Enterprise Maps
for Business team.
My name's Dylan Thomas.
I'm a community maps manager.
And with me today is
Sean who is a product
manager on Google
Earth Enterprise.
I'm very glad you're hear.
SEAN MADAY: Well, I
appreciate the opportunity.
DYLAN THOMAS: All right,
well, let's get right into it.
SEAN MADAY: All right.
DYLAN THOMAS: Who are you?
What do you do?
SEAN MADAY: All right.
So my name is Sean Maday.
I've been at Google
about 3 and 1/2 years.
My current role
is product manager
for Google Earth Enterprise and
Google Maps Engine Portable.
Before this, I was
in this current role,
I was a sales engineer
for about 2 and 1/2 years
and had a great opportunity
to travel the world,
talk to folks who were
using maps, Google Maps,
in their enterprise
applications,
and help them find new creative
ways to unlock their data.
DYLAN THOMAS: Cool.
So it sounds like
you've been doing
GEO for at least a little while.
How did you get into GEO?
SEAN MADAY: Yeah,
it's a good question.
I am not a classically
trained geographer.
I was in the Air
Force for five years,
and as an intelligence
officer, big part of what I did
was related to mapping
and remote sensing.
So I became a user and became
enamored with the Google
Enterprise product and I have
been working around the product
ever since.
DYLAN THOMAS:
Enamored ever since.
SEAN MADAY: Absolutely.
DYLAN THOMAS: So I am a
classically trained geographer.
I'm not sure what that
means exactly, but yeah.
SEAN MADAY: You can
probably tell me
things about plate tectonics
that I wouldn't understand.
DYLAN THOMAS: I should do that.
SEAN MADAY: OK, maybe that
could another "Behind the Map"
segment.
DYLAN THOMAS: Exactly, right.
SEAN MADAY: I look
forward to that.
DYLAN THOMAS: So
one other question
before we get to what the
customers were wondering about
is just wondering
what you've got
excited about maps or
business right now.
What's interesting?
SEAN MADAY: Yeah,
overall, I think,
the general trend
that has me excited,
has a lot of my
co-workers excited
is just the consumerization
of mapping technology.
And this technology
used to be reserved
for just those remote sensing
scientists or those GIS
professionals.
DYLAN THOMAS: Those classically
trained geographer types.
SEAN MADAY: Those darn
classically trained
geographers.
And today, we're seeing
this technology just become
ubiquitous.
It's embedded in apps.
I used Uber this morning
to get to a shuttle stop,
and sure enough, I
dropped a pin on a map,
and maps have become
just another part
of the way we
communicate data and we
share information
with one another.
And that trend is
really exciting.
DYLAN THOMAS: So the
ubiquity of it, right?
Is that what you're--
SEAN MADAY: Yeah, absolutely.
And that ubiquity has so many
neat enterprise use cases.
I was talking to an
organization recently
that manages a large campus
of hospital buildings,
and they were using our
Google Maps Coordinate
to manage their tech support.
So when they dispatch
technical service reps out
into the field, they'd
go to fix a printer,
say, and they could on this
app, on this mobile app,
bring in floor plants
from Google Maps Engine,
and so they could just see not
only Google's road network,
but then the authoritative
floor plans--
DYLAN THOMAS: The business data.
SEAN MADAY: Exactly, that the
University had shared with them
or the university medical
system had shared with them.
And then from there,
they could also--
one of the products I'm
really focused on is offline
and how do we make sure
that they have that map
data available to them if
they are in the basement
or they are in some kind
of austere situation,
where they don't
have any connectivity
to the outside world.
DYLAN THOMAS: Yeah, yeah, cool.
So I think it's something we
both heard from customers,
actually, is just the
consumerization piece doesn't
just mean bringing the consumer
stuff to the enterprise
necessarily, but
the learning factor.
If I know how to use
Google Maps on my phone,
I kind of know how to use the
Coordinate app, for example,
right?
SEAN MADAY: Absolutely.
DYLAN THOMAS: It's just
pretty straightforward.
So you mentioned offline.
This is a good segway.
We've got a number of
questions from customers
who I mentioned
while talking to you,
and the questions started
rolling in, so let's get to it.
SEAN MADAY: Sounds good.
DYLAN THOMAS: The first one is
about Google Earth Enterprise,
which is a product you're
a product manager for.
SEAN MADAY: Absolutely.
DYLAN THOMAS: And how that
fits with Google Maps Engine?
So how do the two
products look together?
SEAN MADAY: Yeah, absolutely.
That's a great question.
And so Google Earth
Enterprises, really Google's
first maps for business product.
It's been around
for eight years.
And we have just an extremely
loyal customer base,
who've done really interesting
things with technology.
DYLAN THOMAS: Yeah.
SEAN MADAY: Google
Maps Engine is
kind of a new kid on the block,
but for the last couple years
Google has invested a
lot of time and resources
in the [? StandingUp, ?] a
very unique geospatial platform
that runs in Google's cloud.
DYLAN THOMAS: OK.
SEAN MADAY: Same cloud that
provides YouTube and Gmail,
and those sorts of things.
DYLAN THOMAS: Yeah.
SEAN MADAY: So it's
really exciting
for me, when I look at
these two technologies,
is that as we have now petabytes
of data and tens of terabytes
of data that customers may
have in their repository.
They can go to
Google Maps Engine,
they can process that
off-loading or offloading
that process that
they would normally
do on their own hardware,
they can now do in the cloud.
DYLAN THOMAS: All
right, got it, got it.
So you're saying that
GEE of enterprise,
you've got the
processing component
and then you've got
the serving component.
And the processing component
is really compute intensive,
so with GME, you
could offload that
to Google's infrastructure?
SEAN MADAY: Absolutely.
And then maybe you have
some proprietary layers
that you know you just don't
want to share the cloud
or you legally can't
share with the cloud--
DYLAN THOMAS: OK.
SEAN MADAY: We are going
to give you tools on prem
to make sure that you
process those, combine
that with the data you
have in Google Maps Engine,
and there you have the
best of both worlds.
And so we see GME as an
integral piece of the GEE story,
and GEE as an integral
piece of the GME story.
DYLAN THOMAS: Sounds
like one big story.
SEAN MADAY: It's one big story.
It's a novel.
DYLAN THOMAS: It's a novel.
So other one was about GEE 5.0,
which is a pending release,
so I think you'd
maybe touch on a bit.
And actually, specifically
about WMS support,
which is the open standard
for sharing data, right?
SEAN MADAY: Yeah, I'm really
excited about this GEE 5.0
release.
We've had a ton of
great engineering effort
over the last nine months
or so to get this release
and make it happen.
It's currently out
in the beta form,
so current customers can
download it and install it.
DYLAN THOMAS: OK.
SEAN MADAY: And we're actually
pushing for a production
release on the 24th of October.
So really exciting to
have this on the horizon.
One feature-- there's many
very exciting features
that our team has worked on
here for this GEE 5.0 release--
one of those features is WMS.
DYLAN THOMAS: OK.
SEAN MADAY: And
our folks with WMS
was to give away
four of our customers
to take the imagery that they
have loaded into Google Earth
Enterprise, that
they're going to use
with Google Earth
and Google Maps--
DYLAN THOMAS: Yeah.
SEAN MADAY: --but also make
use of that imagery in some
of their GIS applications, or
remote sensing applications--
DYLAN THOMAS: So like QGIS
or something like that?
SEAN MADAY: Sure, exactly,
ArcMap, QGIS, NASA World Wind.
A way that you could, from
a customer's perspective,
have one repository
of imagery that
could feed both
your Google Maps,
Google Earth, and
your OGC compliant
GIS software suite audiences.
DYLAN THOMAS: So speaking
of OGC compliance,
the question was
specifically asking
about versions around that.
I don't know how much you
can share on that today.
SEAN MADAY: Yes, so
it's a great question.
We are going to support WMS
1.1 and the 1.3 specs, so both
of those specs with the
standard kind of GetMap.
DYLAN THOMAS: Oh,
perfect, OK, great.
SEAN MADAY: Yeah, and
get image requests.
DYLAN THOMAS: Yeah.
SEAN MADAY: And
then the tiles are
going to come out in
their native projection.
So if you're projecting
them from a Mercator map,
those WMS tiles are
going to come out
in Mercator projection.
DYLAN THOMAS: OK.
SEAN MADAY: If you're pulling
the tiles from a 3D database,
they will be in the
[INAUDIBLE] projection
or the flat projection.
And so what we
then would envision
is that our customers can marry
this Google Earth Enterprise
5.0 offering with an open
source tool, like MapServer,
or an open source
utility like GeoServer,
and they could do
cascading re-projection
to take these tiles they are
getting from Earth Enterprise
and re-project them into
any other projections
that their users may require.
DYLAN THOMAS: Oh,
OK, so the WMS piece
we have is the OGC
compliant spec,
but then if you want
to do additional work,
then you can just plug in
whatever open source server
you're interested in using to do
all extra magical stuff there?
SEAN MADAY: Absolutely.
All those re-projection
use cases.
DYLAN THOMAS: Yeah, yeah, cool.
Thanks, let's move
onto another one.
SEAN MADAY: OK.
DYLAN THOMAS: Apparently, you
gave a presentation at ASPRS
in Baltimore.
SEAN MADAY: Oh.
DYLAN THOMAS: And someone saw
it and they have a question.
SEAN MADAY: Well, I don't want
to take too much credit here,
but when I presented
in Baltimore,
the Ravens won the
Superbowl, so I
think I have a lot
to do with that.
DYLAN THOMAS: The effort, yeah.
Well, moving on.
I think the question there
was that you were really
talking about offline and
taking things portable.
And touched on this.
And so what the question is
can you share a little bit more
about that project, generally?
What our approach is
in Maps for Business?
And then, also, to what extent
that moves to GME customers,
as well, from Apps Engine?
SEAN MADAY: Yeah, absolutely.
So I'm really excited
to be part of a team
right now that has been
working on the ability
to cut portable maps and
globes from Google Maps Engine.
DYLAN THOMAS: Yeah.
SEAN MADAY: So you can take
all this data you've uploaded
to the cloud, download it in
whole or maybe just a part
of it as it makes sense,
and then drop that--
it comes down as a single file--
DYLAN THOMAS: OK.
SEAN MADAY: You can drop that
file then on your laptop,
run it with Google
Maps Engine Portable
or very soon you are going
to be able to drop that
on your Android
device and interact
with that map or that 3D globe--
DYLAN THOMAS: Oh, cool.
SEAN MADAY: --from a
tablet or a smartphone.
DYLAN THOMAS: So the
thing you mentioned
there was Google Maps
Engine Portable being
the sort of the file format and
the serving technology there?
SEAN MADAY: Yeah, so we
call those "portable cuts."
It's kind of in the
file format, and then we
have a flexible suite
of serving solutions.
So whether it's a
single Android device,
maybe it's laptop portable in
a small tactical operations
center or a small group
kind of environment;
or even Google Earth
Enterprise Server,
if you need to serve
thousands of users,
you can cut that imagery
terrain and vector data out
of Google Maps Engine,
drop that file, which
could be very large, on your
Google For Enterprise server,
serve it to everybody behind
your firewall on your network.
DYLAN THOMAS: So I think that
sort of comes full circle
to what you were
talking about initially,
where you could
potentially offload
the compute-intensive
processing of data, what
you might consider
the fusing of data.
And then the offline
component, it's actually,
it's what Google Earth
Enterprises today-- except,
we now have a really nice
story with MapsEngine and Earth
Enterprise--
SEAN MADAY: Absolutely.
DYLAN THOMAS: --and
we're adding the ability
to not just use GEE server,
but also some new technology.
SEAN MADAY: Absolutely.
DYLAN THOMAS: Very
nice, OK, thanks.
We have one other question.
It was, what is the
anticipated impacts
to previous versions of
GEE databases and globes
in the new version?
Basically, an upgrade question.
What's the impact?
SEAN MADAY: Yeah, absolutely.
We're keenly interested
in making sure
that our customers can
upgrade seamlessly to GEE 5.0.
DYLAN THOMAS: OK.
SEAN MADAY: So with the
release that we put out
on the 24th of October, we
will have an upgrade guide.
And we've run several different
upgrade scenarios internally
just to make sure that whether
you're upgrading directly
from 4.4 or 4.4.1
to 5.0, we have
good options and good
instructions for you.
Generally, it's going to require
rebuilding the Google Earth
Enterprise database.
DYLAN THOMAS: OK.
SEAN MADAY: And in
some cases, it's
going to require building
the project-level assets.
DYLAN THOMAS: OK,
and so when you
say "in some cases," that's
all in the documentation
you just described, sort of
the upgrade guide, right?
SEAN MADAY: Exactly.
Yeah, and of course, we have
our Enterprise support folks
are always there
to help, if there's
specific questions or unique
environment questions,
jump on the Enterprise
Support Portal, file a ticket,
[INAUDIBLE] and the
team, and my team
will work really hard to
make sure our customers can
make this transition.
DYLAN THOMAS: Great.
I'm glad you mentioned that.
I know I've
mentioned she's going
to be doing a bit more of a
deep dive on what's new in 5.0.
We'll be recording and
releasing that later.
But for now, Sean, thanks very
much, indeed, for joining us.
SEAN MADAY: Oh, that you, Dylan.
DYLAN THOMAS: We appreciate it.
And that's it for this time.
We'll see you next time
on "Behind the Map."